Years ago, not knowing better and let a dentist take on all my mercury fillings, he did so just by drilling them all out.
I assume this person said that they didn't use a mercury vapor, vacuum, did use a rubber dam, did it close off your nasal cavity.
Yeah, I know firsthand other issues with that.
Also, I still have two crowns that are covered in white, but show silver due to my receding gum line.
Yeah, this is a problem a lot of people have silver fillings underneath the crown, and they don't even know what.
All until recently, I used to do oil fully daily, not knowing I shouldn't, if I have silver in my mouth.
Also, I was fully vaccinated as a child in young adults.
My mental toxicity be a contributing factor to cancer, as well as other health factors.
Well, absolutely, mental mercury has aluminum and vaccines and things and steps that they're sprayed in the air is causing all sorts of health issues.
It's a huge, huge, huge problem.
The difficult thing is, is that you can't really do, you know, chelation therapy or try to chelate the side of your body when you have such large quantities still launched in your teeth.
I've had people that want to get their mercury fillings open, they have so many literally they'd have to get every tooth on their mouth pulled.
It's just impossible task.
You just got to learn to fight what giants that you can fight without opening up battles that you're not able to defeat.
So